electric vehicles increasingly a target
of the anti-everything right wing as
many of you know i am four electric
vehicles i have an electric vehicle i
think they're great in many ways nothing
is perfect everything has pros and cons
i think that the reality of electric
vehicles is good enough i don't feel
like anything needs to be exaggerated
about them but also a lot of the claims
made about electric vehicles that are
negative claims are false and i'm going
to play for you such an example on fox
news yesterday judge jeanine pirro this
is an image of geraldo rivera but he's
on a program with judge jeanine pirro
she delivered
an unhinged tirade about electric
vehicles that ends up with her yelling
what if you live in middle america
who gives a damn about what's happening
in new york city i mean completely
unintelligible listen to the specific
claims she makes and we'll talk about
them one by one
i submit respectfully that if they want
to lead by example then they've got to
bite the bullet
okay this is what i think
i think when joe biden came out and he
told those mom-and-pop gas stations to
lower the prices and do it now they all
got scared of joe and they said we
better lower the price of gas look
that's all hogwash what this guy is
doing right now is he's taking credit
for something that he didn't do okay and
now they're if he declares this
emergency he's going to everybody's
going to say oh my gosh what are we
going to do there's not going to be any
gas and even though he's taking credit
for more gas
they've got to buy now an electric
vehicle okay so
so before she even gets into electric
vehicles this is the same old story
biden gets all of the blame for the
run-up of gas prices and none of the
credit for the decline now i think he
has barely anything to do with both
and i said that under trump i said it
under obama i said it under bush
presidents have very little to do with
gas prices but on fox they blame biden
for the increase and they don't give him
credit but then now she says really the
switcheroo is they want to get you on
electric vehicles an electric vehicle
the average one costs 64 000
the average car costs 46 000
the average american doesn't have a new
car so the average american and when
pete buddha judge says look you may pay
a little more on your car payment the
average american doesn't have a car
payment okay so first of all
the
wow
if you
were to even start if americans don't
have car payments then it's not really
even relevant but the important thing
here is when she talks about the average
price of electric vehicles the number
she states is outdated actually average
price of electric vehicle 2022
um it's down to fifty four thousand
dollars so
let's actually think that through
janine says
nobody can afford electric vehicles okay
average electric vehicle cost 64k
and average non-electric vehicle new
costs 46k okay that's a difference of 18
000
the real average price of an electric
vehicle in 2022 is 54 000 now it's still
more right 54 000 versus 46 000 but
there's a 70 up to a 7 500 federal
credit for people who buy electric
vehicles so all of a sudden your 8 000
difference becomes much smaller and then
you have the fact that on average it
costs one-third of what it costs in a
gas vehicle to go one mile with an
electric vehicle so janine is just wrong
the the cars aren't cheap for sure
but when you consider the gas savings
and the credit
it's actually not as big of a difference
anymore now not everybody gets new cars
that's absolutely true let's continue
the average american is driving a car
that he or she has had for a long time
and they're not making payments the car
is paid for it's old they're just
surviving and deciding if they have
enough gas to go to work and to buy the
food that they need and the sad part of
all this is that they don't understand
america they don't understand what's
going on in america when they say oh
just buy an electric vehicle or oh the
government should should get electric
vehicles if we don't have the
infrastructure for electric vehicles we
can in part because the government
hasn't invested enough in that
infrastructure right i mean the
infrastructure will follow demand we are
already seeing that in areas where you
see more electrical vehicle sales you
see more companies enter the market and
say we're gonna do charging stations
we're gonna do portable charging we're
gonna do uh a device that you can keep
in your trunk with a fully charged
battery to charge right out of it and
then you just swing by and you get one
that's already charged and leave yours
all of these things are they talk about
the market allow the market to function
i'm not going to tell you who it is but
the guy that i buy some of my cars from
he says to me janine i'm buying one he
said i don't even like it i don't want
to drive it i can't drive it anywhere
but around town
this is oh let me finish this is all
make-believe nonsense where america is
not supporting these green lunatics i
was driving it to work today went to
starbucks
charging 10 charging stations in the
starbucks right right it's growing the
infrastructure will work what if you're
an american living in middle america
who gives a damn about what's going on
in new york city next to the starbucks
so the other thing that they often will
talk about with middle america is
there's no infrastructure you don't have
places to charge most people don't need
to charge anywhere other than home this
is the other
uh the the um anti-electric vehicle
uh or i don't want to call it an
industry the uh opponents of electric
vehicles will often say these vehicles
just don't have long enough ranges
where you can count on
going and coming back from work even in
many cases even in middle america that's
an even bigger issue this is completely
untrue the median electric vehicle has
gone from being able to drive 68 miles
without a charge in 2011
to 234 miles right now that's the median
vehicle and there's ones with much
longer ranges very few people even in
middle america have a commute that would
make that median range a problem let's
be conservative your goal is i want to
go to work and back
and i don't want to be cutting it close
i want 20 percent battery remaining when
i get home
with the median electric vehicle 234
mile range you can do a 94 mile commute
now i don't mean 94 miles round trip i
mean you can go 94 miles to work
come back 94 miles and still have 20
percent battery left over you get the
gas savings
you can get the federal federal uh
credit for the vehicle
and you don't have to charge anywhere
but at home in addition to that many
electric uh um companies
now give you rebates if you charge
during off-peak hours i just set up my
vehicle now by charging after
i think it's 9 00 p.m um by charging
only after 9 p.m i get something like uh
you know five cents per kilowatt hour
back and i get a check every month
uh it
they they are lying okay these are these
are simply not issues the cost of the
vehicles sure it's coming down the range
of the vehicles it's increasing the cost
of the electricity it's a fraction of
what gas cost and of course we could
have instead of subsidized gasoline
we could get rid of those subsidies let
the cost of gas really reflect the total
cost including the environmental cost
which we don't we don't have accurate
gas prices in the united states and
further subsidize the electric vehicles
so janine is completely unhinged
attacking everything that is good if
janine is against it you should consider
whether it's something we should be very
happy about